guys if you've been paying attention on
my channel I have been reviewing every
single David Fincher movie leading up to
gone girl this Thursday I have had to
speed through this because my week in LA
really put me behind but right now I'm
talking about the girl with the Dragon
Tattoo
David Fincher returned to some of his
more darker roots with this film with a
social network it was dark on an
emotional level with Curious Case of
Benjamin Button wasn't really dark at
all and with this movie Fincher was
really able to play to his strengths
it's about a guy played by Daniel Craig
who's being accused of something he
didn't do who is being forced to
investigate a series of murders to help
clear his name and the investigator who
is helping him played by rooney mara
who's rather unconventional in her ways
he's investigating a murder that took
place amongst a family the person who
hires him played by Christopher Plummer
is convinced that someone in his family
is responsible for this murder but it's
not just about that it's about the
chemistry between Rooney Mara and Daniel
Craig and how their odd strange
relationship helps both of them as
people The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
believe it or not is one of my favorite
David Fincher movies is it as best no
but I do think it is an excellent crime
detective thriller in the terrific
editing and score especially the opening
theme song make this movie extremely
fast paced which is one of the things
that Fincher is able to do so well he's
able to make these really long two and a
half hour two three our movies where you
don't feel any slow time Rooney Mara is
absolutely mesmerizing in this movie she
really went to some deep dark place is
getting real piercings and stuff like
that for her role I mean she really sunk
deep into this character and Daniel
Craig was her equal they did such a
fantastic job together they had amazing
chemistry and I really hope that Fincher
and them make the last two movies in the
book series I would love if they would
do that now I know what you want to know
you want to know if I've seen the
original Swedish film I have I think
it's pretty good but I do like the
American remake better I think that is
made with much more skill this is one of
those movies that even though it's
fictional you feel yourself getting
involved in the case that they are
trying to solve
I love murder mysteries like that
whereas you are watching the movie you
remind yourself holy crap I'm watching a
movie right now and yet I am so
interested and invested in these
characters and I
really want to know what's going to
happen the look of the snowy land and
the big estates it's so creepy it really
lends to the eerie vibe this movie gives
off also can I just talk a little bit
about the ending without spoiling it um
that is some creepy I love it
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo is a
really really damn good movie and I hope
you guys check it out if you haven't
seen it because I would love to see the
next two in the trilogy be completed by
Fincher I'm gonna give this movie an A I
think it's fantastic I love it and that
is it for my David Fincher series of
reviews I'll have my review for gone
girl Thursday night I can't wait to see
it thank you so much for sticking with
me in these videos I hope that you check
out my previous ones I reviewed every
David Fincher movie previously except
for alien 3 hope you guys check those
out if you haven't already as always
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes